the way that Phil Knight used to talk
about Nike I don't know if you've ever
heard the story he was speaking at a
large conference and he stood up and he
said to the audience if any of you have
ever run for exercise can you please
stand up most of the room stood up he
said if you run at least once a week
please keep standing at the rail sit
down most room sits down he says if you
run on you know twice a week please keep
standing
he says we run three times a week rain
or shine regardless of the weather or
the temperature please keep saying
there's no smattering of people in the
room and he looks out at them and he
says the next time you're out there
before the Sun is up it's dark it's cold
and it's wet and you're running by
yourself we're the ones standing under
the Lamppost cheering you on that's how
he described Nike in an instant you
understand what just do it means it has
nothing to do with winning it has
everything to do with trying
it has everything with doing
and his story his ability his narrative
captured that so exquisitely and when
Nike's at their best they celebrate the
ones who do not the ones who win